[Music]
okay okay
my keys are buried in my purse crap
cardi B doesn't have to deal with crap
like this guilty or my fashion guilty
pleasure is spending money
oh if there is one thing I like to try
it's to try to be more like my girl
cardi B okay luckily I am joined now by
Jenny Boyd the queen of bling
who does cardi B's nails Jenny we bow to
you you are an artiste yeah she's
amazing and I'm gonna get meals like
cardi B today okay I cannot do like
cardi B style okay yes perfect Jenny the
queen of bling knows exactly what to do
this is the top line treatment this nail
I just do something similar Bakari last
night thank you
about how long does it take this set
took about two hour look we love how
cardi says okay okay does she say that
to you yes yes she just says that in
everyday life oh she always something to
say see how they have something funny to
say
did you do her nails for the Pepsi
commercial yeah please help me just do
right why I'm blue
so I put red white and blue Sawatzky and
stuff how long or cardies nails Scottie
Nell is inside of this one so you make
sure you can't handle not gonna do like
three-inch p.m. money how often are you
doing cardies nails I don't call him
nail like once a month no you did cardis
nails for the Grammys yes I see tell me
they don't want too much bling so that's
why I don't do this much bling this time
but sometimes she wants a lot yeah
sometimes you learn a lot of things
what's the most bling you've ever done
the mark thing is like giant big and
then ten finger bling do you do like a
Swarovski crystals like hundreds how
many are we - yeah okay we are here at
sugarcoat salon in Los Angeles but
you're based in New York yes so is cardi
flying to New York or is she flying you
out here Japan Japan it's like a big
event I've I come here and small events
sometimes you just go to me
how long have you been doing your nails
I'm doing else six year I'm so glad to
work with Hearst from the bottom to the
top she never never give me one time
attitude she's so nice I love her she's
so humble well I do it there once you
sleep - really yeah
yes she gotta take a nap she's tired
yeah she has culture one time I do her
nails she framing the money video and
she's so tired she knocked out and then
I do her nails to sleep E&C wake up you
say oh wait yeah
oh my god I'm glad now she's not even
know what I'm doing she just trusts it
just get up and then CC on Nancy so
happy
now it's car D always done the long
nails yes once you have coucher she cuts
down a little bit but now culture is so
big so people buy longer than how old do
you think culture will be when Carly
takes her and for her first nails
oh maybe two yeah all set love bling
once you don't have bling all set over
you go get somebody
there's offset get his nails done not
fake nails be like to see yeah you did
get a manicure
what do you call the shape of these this
one they recast a little sexy and a
murder weapon
how do you feel I feel like a woman
who's changing growing becoming a
superstar make sure I just stabbed you
Jenny isn't just stabbed Jenny I just
stabbed the queen of bling and then I'm
gonna use my crystal gel oh my god that
glue Jenny how many crystals
am I getting today you got a lot of
crystal I could not you encounter these
are a lot well we want the full
treatment from the queen of bling yes I
love this I guess Jenny my mind is blown
my mind is blinged how many crystals did
you put on these nails because I had
just something I put big and small all
together it's like a hundred something
crystal in there and I love it because
it's kind of that matte really makes the
bling pop started from the bottom now
we're curtains okay I'm not good for the
next card Evie
[Music]
okay
my keys are buried in my purse
crap cardi B doesn't have to deal with
crap like this
yo C alright problem with the nails is
there's no contingency plan if things
don't go as planned
practice practice practice practice
practice practice practice
[Music]
to be safe in the car great great with
you continuing my book that is great
this is easy you're gonna head back to
work
hit up my desk and continue my day at
the office okay what the key is to not
you can't actually grip the wheel it's
about a flat a flat turning
I'm so hungry I am very hungry
[Music]
crush it oh snap snap snap okay I'm
gonna get it I'm gonna get it great you
know that's when after fabulous get our
mic on so so you have to do our job
might as well as performed at the
Grammys
crap
[Music]
it didn't go well
[Music]